c'est non nous allons maintenant
procéder à l'audition du acquise
histoire du procureur général des
proches de la république ne le lis je
prends les pieds leurs deux chambres
dans la robe de chez team championne
elle
si la robe de chambre et ça si c'est une
chambre c'est une robe de chambre
d'acier bon cessé de rigoler cassel ça
va être dur pour vous maintenant
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri il est
un proverbe latin plein de bon sens qui
dit malheur aux séducteurs les portes du
paradis lui sont à jamais fermé en latin
oui bon c'est duke taurus [ __ ]
paradisio mme que dell alors malheur à
vous jean pierre cassel
malheur à vous qui avez consacré votre
vie à user de votre charme affolant pour
prendre au filet de votre séduction nos
dettes ménagères française rendu
pantelante d'amour sous vos troubles
regard pervers aux longs cils orientaux
recourbé en demi lune dès son plus jeune
âge messieurs les jurés l'accusée savait
usées cyniquement de son charme étrange
pour subjuguer les faibles femmes en
1939 alors qu il redoublait sa
maternelle au lieu d'aller à la guerre
comme tout le monde
la maîtresse d'école lui demanda un jour
que fait le toutou le toutou fait whaou
a répondu l'accusé où habite le poisson
repris la maîtresse le poisson habite
dans l'eau dit l'enfant et où est le
petit oiseau dit hélas la maîtresse le
petit oiseau il est là ricane à
l'odieuse enfants et joignant le geste à
la parole
cette audience publique ici cet horrible
j'ajouterai pour pour l'anecdote que la
malheureuse institutrice bouleversé ne
retrouva son équilibre que quatre ans
plus tard en 1943 en s'engageant comme
chef scène dans les milices du maréchal
pétain ou l perfectionner ses
connaissances ornithologiques sur des
résistants prisonniers
il est un autre proverbe arabe celui là
mais plein de bon sens également qui dit
dini chalco côté mickeal taureau c'est à
dire qui séduit 1,9 séduit un boeuf
ainsi le sieur cassel va-t-il
s'enfonçait de plus en plus profondément
dans le détournement de loot et
l'incitation de majeur à la débauche il
ne s'en cache même pas l'infâme je suis
primesautier clame-t-il bien au
primesautier du latin primus le premier
saut tard et celui qui saute
d'ailleurs il passe son temps étendue
dans le curriculum vitae qui l'a confié
à notre bouleversante petit greffière
honnête la troublante marina il avoue
j'ai même été étendue trois fois au bac
je vous le demande
messieurs les jurés ce que c est une
position pour passer un examen
qui s'étonnera après de tels aveux de
voir que la carrière de l'accusé
jalonnée de films aux titres éloquemment
lubrique je suis désolé monsieur le
président le titre lubrique comme
l'amant de cinq jours où il a séduit
tour à tour les 70 bluebell girls ali
baba et les quarante chanteurs où il a
séduit les choeurs de l'armée rouge
quand passent les cigognes où il a
séduit les six gendarmes de saint tropez
quand passent les douze cogne où il a
séduit un car de crs le chagrin et la
pitié ou même harris et séduit et enfin
un peu calypso où il a séduit le
commandant cousteau
je parle même pas de son rôle dans la
peau et vous même ce président avoue ne
chômait pas en tant que séducteur
monsieur cassel oserez vous avouer à la
cour quel rôle vous tenez dans une
récente version polonaise d'alice au
pays des merveilles
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous même
le rôle du lapin le lapin rejoindre la
merci madame
et ce n'est pas par hasard si l'accusé
tourner en pologne messieurs les jurés
il boit comme un pape comme un polonais
voit comme un polonais voit ça c'était
pas au dossier
j'ai découvert qu'il buvait d'ailleurs
il ne s'en cache même pas accusé ce que
vous voulez lire vous même marina je
vous en prie à la cour la profession de
foi de michel bouquet que vous avez fait
votre que vous avez clamé récemment à
télérama le 16 janvier à propos de la
halle de votre alcoolisme voulez-vous le
lire
l'acteur doit être plein bah voilà met
pas plein de vide maintenant plein de
vinassan vous êtes témoin plein de
vinasse il avoue la femme bien mesdames
et messieurs les jurés je pense que cet
homme doit être puni par où il a péché
si je peux m'exprimer regardant oui oui
je pense que pour lui faire passer le
goût des femmes et du vin je propose
qu'on enferme à la prison de vichy
célestins avec alice fabrique je n'ai
rien n'est fait non non
[Musique]